all right we have two more of these
quite frankly very sad stories about
covet deaths even though these are what
some people call
justice in some way i still find these
very sad let's start with the first one
a dozen or more of you emailing me this
deputy district attorney who opposed
vaccine mandates
has died from covid at 46 years old
kelly ernby was a republican she ran for
california state assembly in 2020
she said there's nothing that matters
more than our freedoms right now at a
rally against vaccine mandates last
month
she is now dead
this was the orange county deputy
district attorney kelly earnby
california republican activist
opposed vaccine mandates of all kinds
her boss district attorney todd spitzer
announced her death on facebook quote
the orange county district attorney's
office is utterly heartbroken by the
sudden and unexpected passing of deputy
district attorney kelly earnby kelly was
an incredibly vibrant passionate
attorney who cared deeply about the work
that we do as prosecutors and deeply
about the community we all fight so hard
to protect
[Music]
ben chapman chair of the greater costa
mesa republicans praised ernby as an
inspiration and confirmed she died from
coveted complications
my heart is broken and i'm in tears
wrote ben i lost a dear friend to covet
complications
ernby ran an unsuccessful campaign for
california state assembly in 2020.
in december she spoke against vaccine
mandates at a rally organized by the
right-wing student group turning post
usa
now i actually don't know if that's an
error and they meant turning point usa
um i was not able to find that
definitively but in any case she
in speaking against all vaccine mandates
said there's nothing that matters more
than our freedoms right now
46 years old and she has died of covid
and it is just another one of these
reminders that listen i'm with
i'm with you
and the science in saying this
disproportionately is hitting older
people
this disproportionately is hitting
unhealthy people obesity is a big risk
factor number of other things
but when you've got a bell curve
distribution
uh or even in this case what may be a
pareto distribution skewed towards the
older and the the um people with
comorbidities
when you have a planet of nearly eight
billion people you're going to get
random
younger
in some cases perfectly healthy people
that are going to die
and if it were me
i don't want to take that chance my my
dad the other day sent me a great
analogy to winter tires
which is you know
sometimes all season tires are perfectly
fine even in winter
sometimes you can go an entire winter
and it doesn't even snow in the
northeastern places where it snows
sometimes it can snow and you've got the
uh all-season tires
and you slip but you don't crash
uh but wouldn't you rather still have
the winter tires because there might be
a situation where they really do protect
you and prevent you from getting into an
accident that that's really the
perspective
on the vaccination stuff so 46 year old
earnby has died of covid
and we have another one of these stories
that in some sense is even more bizarre
one of our sponsors today is blue
bluechew a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping